do a pre-production checklist absolutely
we always start with a schedule in the
budget with looking for locations
locking locations as you know as soon as
you can because that's very important
for us in general for a movie if you
don't have the right location then
you're in trouble and I don't think
that's something you need to leave for
last-minute
and then we start to do casting and
casting process and then crewing up and
obviously you always set a date ahead of
time hey this is what I like to shoot so
if you have the location locked you kind
of set the date by you know making a
deal and unlocking that ensure that can
be stressful because you already put
some money down and you you know rented
something but in the same time you kind
of can stab that stop that train from
from going so yeah we do cannot think
that's something that we take seriously
and also you either call your people you
work with or you know interview people
for other positions differently
collaborators and that's how we do it
once we cast we do rehearsals and meet
with you know department heads before
the shoot and make sure everything is in
place and we're available to everybody
24 hours a day for questions and
meetings and we try to like I said we
try to have as many things locked in
place as possible but you always have to
be flexible for things that can come up
somebody can drop last-minute it's
always something like that that's why I
you know is have more resumes around
because you never know you might have to
replace last minute or something can
fall through it you know we like to
prepare as well as possible but things
will happen no matter what it's the
nature of the beast right so when you
find the location how much time are you
giving yourself once you lock that
location in for then you know you have
to do casting crew up all these
different things
for this shoot you know that depends too
on the location sometimes you know if
it's the desert and it's like something
more open like that or a theater in town
that you kind of can't you know work
with them but like it's you know easier
to book let's say you know sense maybe
you have like a couple of months at
least but I remember like I know feature
we need this feature play course I was
telling about the stages that you know
we videotape for the pitch packaging and
everything once we finally got the money
from the investors my first you know
phone call was to them to book the
stages I remember I was trying to shoot
in the summer and it was kind of like in
springtime when I was calling while the
stages are not available till the rest
of the year said I'm gonna have a heart
attack I'm like I'm gonna lose the money
from the investors if I don't shoot by
the end of the year so all this like all
of a sudden big networks they were like
hey they booked the place so I finally
got something FINA got something with
them to shoot in October which was fine
gave us more time to prep because we're
building sets and miniatures and
costumes and everything I was a lot of
prep to do so in retrospect I was kind
of like a blessing in disguise because
they gave us more prep work but that
determined everything so it's not always
up to you you know you're dealing with
different situations so that kind of
increased our you know prep time but I
was good in that case that's usually
around a couple of months I would say
but you know obviously depends on each
movie you know how much you have to do
if it's period or if it's set in the
future if it's contemporary we have a
bit less time to prep it because it's
you know what tag is here especially if
you have our daughter locations or
locations they're a bit easier to get do
your forecast a movie without locking in
the location no I don't think so no hard
at least have an idea of what I might
yeah yeah yeah because it's kind of goes
hand in hand you don't wanna waste
people's time and tell them what in the
audition I need
you because when we audition people we
kind of know when we're gonna be
scheduled or scheduled to shoot so we
tell people dates like we need you these
dates we even put that in the ads are
you available because we don't want to
waste anybody's time you know different
people have different commitments and we
you need to be prepared and like people
knowing advance so they can clear the
schedules and everything so that's kind
of how it works on the audition we
already tell them a date of some sort so
we we know
you